just keeps on winning doesn't he he's
been amazing five and over the 382
tied for the american league lead and
wins got his fifth victory
last friday against baltimore mark of
the batter
he's hitting 238 five homers
popped him up short right chavis out
gonzalez coming over
gonzalez makes the play and that was in
fair territory
that's a nice play anytime you can run
that far
get to the ball with the willie mays
basket catch
loriano 244 seven home runs
and a good thing he was right there
raffy up and over
got him erod off to a quick start one
two three
well the man on the mound for the green
and gold james caprilian
made his major league debut last year
against the san francisco giants back in
august
was up and down from the outside a few
times did not pitch
today marks his
starting debut at the major league level
first big league start
marwin offers last night at 211 with one
homer
that one's tagged down the line it'll
keep on rolling piscotti makes a
terrific play
here's the throw and it's not gonna get
him as he dives in
piscotti did everything he could with a
sliding play down the right field line
what a play
and jd at first for xander
two-two pitch swang and a miss he got
him no bogarts
chased the pitch that looked like he was
off the plate and it's a huge strikeout
he's about to say you can't let this guy
off the hook right here
well that will fall on christian vasquez
shoulders 265
two home runs for christian loaded up
with two away and caprilian with a 3-0
pitch
[Applause]
red sox take a one-nothing lead olson
one for three
yesterday drove in a run
center field straight away verdugo
racing back hard to the track and can't
get to it
that'll bounce right back to renfro
runner taking the turn around
second here's the play
what a throw oh my god forget about the
cut-off man
wow forget about it i said he's gonna go
for three why not he falls down for dugo
he
pits amy heaves this ball all the way in
one hop perfect
you won't see that all year round
biscotti ripping a single
and it brings up the catcher's sean
murphy here's the pistol i'm in the 1-2
to murph is driven out to left center
field up the alley long run and nobody's
going to get it
it goes to the wall biscotti's around
second going to third they're going to
wave him
he's rounding third and there'll be no
throw by bogarts
it's a double to left center by murphy
and the a's in the top of the second
have tied it up
one gun and lowry
lowry admiring the pitch and he struck
him out
paul just got the corner he shakes his
head i tell you i don't blame him
so two away ramon lauriano steps up he
ground it out to third his first at bat
and in there for strike three
strikes out two in a row lorriano's not
happy
so he's chewing on ryan wills just a
little bit
he got thrown out loriano has been
ejected
once he threw the helmet and the bat and
ramone is full of fire man and he led
ryan wills the whole blood dumper habit
fourth inning tied 1-1 and a 2-2 from
eduardo
caught on and missed he put him away he
struck out three in a row
well that changed up lefty on lefty
works and especially when it
the bottom drops out of it
swung on and missed out he goes hey
that's four consecutive strikeouts back
to back
cheese balls huh boom boom back behind
the count three and one
boom boom see you later thank thee
scotty on at first and the o2 pitch from
eduardo
at 94 miles an hour eddie has struck out
six a great inning there
send it in jerome here's the one pitch
and elvis it's a drive to left center up
the alley and nobody's there
it's going to crash off the monster
verdugo plays the kirim
moreland goes to third and elvis will
cruise into second
makes it there safely and with nobody
out the asf runners at second and third
and that'll bring up jed
talking about hitting with runners in
scoring position he's had
500 this year taps this one towards
bogarts
gonna get a run home flip to first
lowry's out give him an rbi give
moreland a run scored and give the a's a
2-1 lead
and they just called the block and the
a's are going to get another run
elvis anders trots in to score and it's
three to one and he took a look and he
forgot to step off watch
started
leaping a play here by chamus to haul it
in
and that will retire the side but the
a's do strike for two they lead it three
to one
gonzales walks that'll bring up alex
who's walking five to left
the 3-1 right back to him
on the outfield right past the shortstop
down to third moves gonzalez and
stopping there
yeah we've seen that movie before this
year ground ball back to the pitcher
rushes to throw
taps this one perrian grabs it and he
underhands to home and now they're going
to have gonzalez in a rundown
chapman tags gonzales missed him but he
gets them the second time
and the runners stay at first and second
so one out here is xander bogart
and he got him swinging with a fastball
two outs that
is caprilian's dad
getting a fist bump he's got his fingers
crossed now
endeavors at the plate three and two two
outs runners will take off
and the pitch is a swing and a miss in
the dirt murphy picks it up
he throws to first in time devers is out
and capralian gets out of the jam what a
performance by the young man
his father's pumped so are we three to
one a's lead after five
the top of the sixth inning with the a's
leading three to one
and matt olsen hits one high and deep
and
that baby is gone a high towering
shot into the seats and right for olsen
his eighth of the year
it's four to one the a's lead the red
sox have a man on
and endeavors will be the batter one man
out there goes bogarts
i chop and that's gonna roll into right
field
xander was running there goes devers
he's trying for second he's gonna dive
in there
safely and the red sox have runners at
second and third with one down
gutsy by denver plays right in front of
him and he was hustling out of the box
so red sox trying to climb back in this
game late one down
second and third for vasquez
served to the right side scooped up here
comes in her bull guy's trying to score
and he is out at home he is cut down at
home plate
but that's going to wind up a double
play what's that left hand let's see
how he got the back before the hand was
in yep
very aggressive base running right there
he's out at home
run means nothing red sox are down 4-1
in the last of the ninth inning and if
they fail to rally they're going to drop
their third in a row
two-two pitch swing and a miss he struck
him out so deekman
has a nice easy ninth inning and
congratulations to the caprarian family
james caprara the young man on the right
gets his first big league win nicely
done and his
father is psyched